hey everyone welcome back to another
tutorial in this build with me Series
where every month I'll be walking you
through step by step how to build an AWS
mini project for today's project we'll
be using two AWS Services Amazon S3 and
Amazon quickside we'll also be using a
data set provided by bright data with a
list of 50 000 best-selling products on
amazon.com my goal for this video is to
provide you with instructions on how you
can use AWS services to create
visualizations from large data sets so
if you're someone learning AWS cloud and
want to build your Hands-On Tech skills
I'd highly recommend following along and
pausing the video when you need before
we get started please give this video a
like and comment below with the phrase
let's build together okay so here's an
overview of what we're going to be doing
today we'll start by downloading a data
set of 50 000 best-selling Amazon
products then we'll store it into an
Amazon S3 bucket after that we'll
connect the S3 bucket with Amazon
quicksite to create a few interesting
visualizations now let's jump straight
into it and download the data set to do
this head over to my GitHub page where I
have stored a copy of the data set
you'll need to download this CSV file
named
amazonbesseller.csv and also this Json
file names manifest.json which will be
used later for quick site to access the
S3 bucket so click on each of these
and press download
and press Ctrl s
to save it into your downloads folder
we're going to do the same thing here
for the manifest.json file so click raw
control s and then press save
and you can see now that I have both of
these files in my downloads folder by
the way I want to quickly show you where
I got this data from We're actually
using a subset of data from a huge data
set that was provided to me by bright
data if you haven't heard of bright Data
before there are leading data collection
company that collects public web data at
scale they have web scripting Tools in
their IDE as well as ready to use data
sets the reason we're using bright data
is because we need a data source and in
my projects I try to find real life data
to keep things interesting as you can
see here they provided me with 11
gigabytes of data showing a list of the
Amazon bestseller products and this is
pretty cool because normally I would
have to manually scrape the data from
the amazon.com website and then clean it
up before using it but since they
provided us with the data set we don't
have to worry about the web scraping
part so in the future if you ever need a
large set of data I'd recommend checking
out bright data and requesting a data
set from them I'll leave a link in the
description below with a discount
alright now that our data has finished
downloading let's move on to the next
step which is to store in an Amazon S3
bucket for this next step let's head to
the AWS Management console and type in
S3
once you're on the S3 console page click
on create bucket so here I'm going to
create a new bucket to store my large
data set I'm going to name it Lucy
Amazon Project but you can name it
anything you'd like keep the rest of the
settings as default and select create
now click on the bucket you've just
created and upload your CSV file we're
going to select our file
and then press upload
so as our Amazon bestseller data list is
downloading we'll need to make a small
change to our manifest.json file so open
up the file and here you'll see that you
have to enter your bucket name so for my
bucket name it was Lucy Amazon Project
so just remember to change the bucket
name section with the name of your own
bucket
all right as you can see here the Amazon
bestseller dataset.csv has been uploaded
but what we have to do now as well is
also to upload the manifest.json file
and in this bucket now you can see we
have our two objects and that's pretty
much all we have to do on the S3 side of
things we're now ready to move on to
Amazon quick side so that we can start
visualizing our data what I recommend
doing now is to duplicate this current
tab so that you have a copy of your S3
Bucket over here but in this new tab
we're going to type in quicksite
if you don't have a quick site account
yet you'll see this page asking you to
sign up for quick site so just click
sign up
and you'll be able to start a free trial
of the Enterprise Edition scroll a bit
down to the bottom and press continue
just make sure you cancel a subscription
before 30 days to avoid unnecessary
charges over here on the account info
I'm going to type in Tech with Lucy as
my preferred account name but again you
could type in any account name you'd
like I'm also going to type in my email
address
and as we scroll down a bit
make sure you select the S3 bucket that
you want to link to quicksite so click
on your S3 bucket and then finish
keep the rest of the settings as default
and click finish
give it a couple of minutes for your
quick side account to be created before
we move on to the next step
nice okay so this took about 30 seconds
for me and you can see that I've now
signed up for Amazon quickside we're
going to click on go to Amazon quick
site
and then you'll see the quick site
interface
so click on data sets and what we're
going to do is import our S3 data set
into quicksite so click on new data set
and then S3
this is where our manifest file comes in
handy so what we have to do is go back
to the S3 tab click on this
manifest.json object and then click copy
S3 URL go back to the type
paste in the URL and this pretty much
provides instructions for quicksite to
import the necessary CSV file I'm just
going to type in Amazon data source
and then click connect
okay and then click visualize
for here just select the interactive
sheet option and give it a few minutes
for your data set to finish importing
you can see here that they've already
imported the column names so
availability brand categories price and
so on so now we're ready to start
creating our first visualization I'm
going to name this sheet most popular
brands and what I want to do for this
visualization is I want to see from this
list of 50 000 best-selling Amazon
products which brands are the most
popular so drag the field brand into
this graph and you can see that it
counts how many times the brand appeared
in the data set I want to sort these
Brands by ascending order to see which
ones are the most popular to do this we
have to click on brand and then sort
options
make sure you sort by the brand and then
for the sort order click on descending
and then press apply
and straight away quicksite has sorted
these products by the most popular
brands to least popular brands so if we
score all the way to the top you'll see
that for this data set in particular
standard Motor Products appears the most
in the data set remember that this data
set is only a subset of the complete
data so this probably isn't actually the
most popular product out of all the
categories but in this subset you'll see
that this is the most popular brand and
if we go back to these fields you can
see that you can pretty much try any
combination to see comparisons between
things like price the brand whether it's
available or not the seller ID and so on
so feel free to play around to create
your own visualizations quicksite
actually lets you create a lot of
different types of graphs so you have
bar charts donut charts pie charts and
even word clouds as well so yeah you'll
see here that there's a few different
options here are some examples of
additional visualizations to create you
could compare the prices of different
products analyze the top selling product
titles or even identify which sellers
have the most products this video
provides a starting point for you to
create your own visualizations so I
definitely encourage you to get creative
with the types of graphs and data sets
that will be useful for both your
business and personal life and if you
end up creating your own visualizations
feel free to share on social media
platforms like LinkedIn and tag me so in
summary what we did was we downloaded a
large data set uploaded it onto Amazon
S3 then created a dashboard using Amazon
quicksite if you'd like to learn more
Amazon also has their own free quick
site workshops that provide more
advanced tutorials so feel free to check
them out if you're interested and if you
ever need a very large custom data set
remember to check out bright data
they're also on the AWS Marketplace and
you can ask them to push through the
data set there alright thanks so much
for watching and remember to subscribe
to the channel to get notified when I
upload my next build with me video